est-ce que la France est toujours le
pays de Voltaire aujourd'hui ah ben non
non ça pour répondre à votre question
clairement non parce qu'effectivement
sur sur cette question de l'islam mais
sur d'autres questions qui ne relèvent
pas de la religion la liberté
d'expression ne se porte pas bien et que
la peur gagne et que
bah oui on a peur d'exprimer des
opinions qui sont tout à fait lisses
parce qu'on a peur des réseaux sociaux
parce qu'on a peur d'être
victime d'attaque de mise au bon de la
société d'accusation d'islamophobie ou
de je ne sais quoi et donc sur tout un
tas de sujets et malheureusement il n'y
a pas que la religion la liberté
d'expression devient
un art difficile à exercer voilà je
voulais parler un peu de liberté
d'expression avec vous parce que vous
êtes aussi un avocat de la liberté
d'expression mais rentrons peut-être
dans le vif du sujet qui est l'Islam
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est une
religion différente ou pas des autres à
ce que vous la désignez comme coupable
on y reviendra des attentats de Charlie
Hebdo mais peut-être une une question
à Rémy brag quand on parle de l'islam de
quoi parle-t-on il est important de
définir les termes est-ce qu'on parle
justement simplement d'une religion
est-ce qu'on parle également d'une
civilisation d'un système juridique et
ensuite est-ce qu'il y a un islam ou
plusieurs islams alors écoutez
l'ennui c'est que nous n'avons qu'un
seul mot pour parler de l'islam alors
que nous avons deux mots au moins pour
parler du christianisme nous parlons de
la chrétienté et du christianisme même
s'il y a pas mal de gens qui en ce
moment commettent l'anglicisme ils
disent chrétiens t parce qu'il pense à
Christiane aider alors qu'il pense qu'il
désigne en fait le christianisme bon la
chrétienté c'est un domaine de
civilisation
qui que l'on peut limiter dans l'espace
et que l'on peut limiter dans le temps
enfin bon c'est un fait de civilisation
c'est pas des gens et ça n'est pas non
plus une croyance c'est plutôt des
pratiques le christianisme bon ben voilà
c'est une foi c'est la foi en
Jésus-Christ comme dernier mot de Dieu
si je puis dire enfin la théologie
indice le Verbe de Dieu bon et les deux
se mélangent aussi peu que
l'islam comme premièrement attitude
fondamentale de remise de soi intégrale
c'est c'est le sens de la racine arabe
entre les mains de Dieu c'est ça se
distingue de l'Islam comme religion avec
disons un système de dogme et de
pratique les fameuses les fameux cinq
piliers que tout le monde connaît ça se
distingue encore de l'islam moi que
j'écrirai là avec une majuscule le
français des ressources que la robe par
exemple n'a pas il met les noms communs
il écrit des noms communs avec une
minuscule et les nombres avec une
majuscule donc l'islam comme
civilisation qui alors là aussi a des
limites géographiques et des limites
chronologiques qui se comprend elle-même
d'ailleurs comme différentes
des autres comme
constituant le domaine de la paix c'est
un mot arabe que tout le monde connaît
DARES salam parce que c'est le nom de la
capitale du de la Tanzanie si je ne me
trompe et puis il y a encore un
quatrième sens quand on dit le réveil de
l'Islam ou des choses comme ça on veut
parler des populations on veut parler
des gens alors évidemment c'est une
distinction qui pour moi bon j'ai pas
besoin d'une grande contention d'esprit
pour la pour la concevoir la distinction
entre les gens et leurs croyances ça
c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire qu'on n'arrive pas je me
permets une petite comparaison qui est
en même temps une plaisanterie à propos
du tabac
tout le monde distingue le tabac des
fumeurs et les fumeurs bon et personne
n'accuserait de fumerophobie les gens
qui mettent sur les paquets de
cigarettes le tabac tout ce grand
guignol
des gens qui sont traqués autonomisés
enfin des horreurs comme ça et je dirais
même où sont les vrais amis des fumeurs
c'est certainement pas les gens qui leur
disent mais non il y a pas de problème
vous n'aurez jamais de cancer du poumon
ou de la vessie non non tout ça c'est de
la blague sont d'ailleurs la plupart du
temps des gens qui vendent des
cigarettes c'est un pur hasard
évidemment c'est comme ça bon le
véritable amis c'est des gens qui disent
attention
bien sûr le tabac ça peut
statistiquement parlant ça augmente en
tout cas radicalement vos chances
d'attraper une saleté alors ben je crois
qu'il faudrait appliquer cette
distinction qui est quand même le
pontosane ça devrait être une évidence
entre alors il se fait que de fait il y
a beaucoup de gens qui ont du mal à
concevoir que si on attaque une religion
quelle qu'il soit on ne veut pas dire
que les adeptes de ladite religion
quelle qu'elle soit à nouveau sont des
imbéciles ou des [ __ ]
justement on arrive au cœur du sujet si
on vous suit bien à Richard Richard
Malka vous dites très souvent on dit
l'islamiste et une petite une petite
minorité et ça n'a rien à voir le mot
qui vient souvent derrière c'est ça n'a
rien à voir avec l'Islam là vous refusez
en fait c'est cette hypocrisie là est-ce
que vous expliquez dans votre livre
c'est que l'islamisme est bien lié à
l'islam est-ce que c'est une maladie de
l'islam est-ce que c'est la religion
elle-même qui est qui est viciée c'est
les mots de feu mon ami
Abdallah medeb l'islamisme et le cancer
de l'islam
mais non oui la métaphore avec le tabac
mais
non mais effectivement j'ai voulu
si j'ai voulu plaider sur la religion
c'est pour dire c'est pour briser des
tabous c'est pour aller au fond des
choses alors il faut le faire avec
beaucoup de précisions pour le coup dans
les mots
éventuellement un peu de bienveillance
mais il faut dire les choses sinon ça
sert à rien or disons les choses depuis
l'origine c'est depuis les tous débuts
de l'islam au 8ème siècle il y a
toujours eu deux visions qui se sont
affrontées et il faut regarder ça en
face il y a une vision qui est une
vision libérale
plaçant la liberté de l'homme en sens
entre la raison c'est l'islam des
premiers siècles de du savoir de la
connaissance pendant que l'Occident
était lui dans l'obscurantisme c'est le
c'est l'islam des grands médecins des
grands chimistes des philosophes de tout
ce qu'on connaît sa durée des siècles
quand même il y avait déjà des des
courants contraires et puis il y a un
islam
la liste qui refuse l'interprétation des
textes qui pensent que le Coran est
incréé et donc qui descend directement
du ciel et donc on ne peut pas
l'interpréter c'est un islam de la
soumission de l'obéissance du refus de
la raison de de l'interprétation et il y
a toujours eu un mouvement de balancier
entre ce désires là mais c'est pas
marginal le wahabisme c'est pas marginal
ça l'était au 19e siècle on considérait
que c'était une secte savoir que les WAB
en profané les tombes des compagnons de
Mahomet et y compris de son épouse
Khadija c'était considéré comme une
véritable secte de fanatique sans aller
jusqu'au mot de Kamel Daoud l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est daech qui a réussi mais
il y a toujours eu et c'est ce Islam là
aussi qui finance partout dans le monde
certains islams alors les islams il y en
a il y en a des centaines le
mériterait un traitement
à part enfin ça n'a rien à voir avec le
reste il y a le chiisme et le sunnisme
il y en a beaucoup mais il y a quand
même une un courant une vision de
l'islam qui est une vision rigoriste
littéralisme fermé depuis l'origine et
mon inquiétude vous risquez en train de
parler des temps présent c'est que ce
courant là devienne l'orthodoxie le
modèle oui c'est le courant qui est
dominant aujourd'hui vous diriez
pas forcément en nombre mais c'est le
courant qu'on entend le plus c'est le
courant le plus revendicatif le plus
militant le plus financé
et c'est le courant qui fait pression et
les autres l'autre courant je comprends
il a pas forcément envie de s'exprimer
puisque c'est pas si important pour lui
la religion ou en tout cas ça se vit
tranquillement pourquoi aller s'exprimer
donc on l'entend pas et donc il y a un
déséquilibre et il y a une pression qui
s'exerce et il y a l'idée de dire le bon
Islam c'est celui-là donc si tu fais pas
le ramadan tu es pas un bon musulman
parce que pour cette Islam là on n'est
jamais un assez bon musulman et c'est
compliqué du coup pour les et il faut le
reconnaître pour les musulmans français
aujourd'hui et pour les musulmans en
Occident parce que pour reprendre une
expression de de une image de gentlean
qui est un historien ils sont pris un
peu entre le marteau de l'islamisme pour
lesquels ils ne seront jamais dans ces
bons musulmans et puis l'enclume des
Identitaires pour lesquelles ils ne
seront jamais d'assez bons européens
vous avez l'extrême gauche qui pense
vers le marteau l'extrême droite vers
l'enclume et la gauche qui dit rien
parce que elle dit plus rien
et la droite non plus donc voilà je
pense qu'il y a une troisième voie à
inventer et mais ça passe par la liberté
d'expression et c'est pour ça que j'ai
voulu écrire là il faut dire qu'il y a
une autre vision et il faut la faire
vivre cette autre vision
[Musique]